hello everyone welcome
um today we want to talk about uh
testing Big Data applications on spark
task and array
so in this talk we will first have a
quick discussion about the general
testing types and then we will talk
about the mindset and good practices in
the end we will have a brief
introduction to Fugue and to see how few
can help testing the Big Data
applications
foreign
there are two main purposes for software
and service testings
to verify the correctness and to verify
the performance on the low level
we have unit testing integration testing
and the regression testing and on the
high level we have acceptance testing
for correctness and the stress testing
for performance
in terms of testing strategies if we
pick unit testing integration testing
and acceptance testing then from the top
level to the bottom level we are moving
from implementation validation to data
validation
and we are moving from technology driven
to business driven
and for Big Data applications the upper
level testings are always easier faster
and cheaper and more importantly the
upper level testings will have better
Tesla coverage
so now let's talk about the mindset when
you design your big data applications
and see how that can affect your
testibility of your your project
so the first thing I want to talk about
is separation of logic
so you must have a very strong sense of
separation of logic when you're
designing your application and there
should be several layers when you design
your application the first layer should
be the core Computing logic that should
be framework agnostic and this part
should be the most unit testable part
and the second layer should be the
orchestration logic where it has to be
framework dependent this part is more
difficult and can be also slower to test
for example if you want to test the
spark application and then you probably
have to have a spark cluster a local
cluster and that can take a lot of time
if you have a lot of such tests foreign
on the bottom layer it is framework
specific Logic for example how do you
create a cluster how do you tear down
that cluster so for this logic it's the
most difficult part to test
um so in in general this part should be
uh covered by the acceptance tests
let's take a look at the first example
subtracting me so assume that you have a
data frame
um we want to group this data frame by
the G column and for for each group we
want to subtract the mean of V from each
value of the V
so here is a spark a native sparkling
implementation Pi spark implementation
actually this function is poorly
designed why because in this function as
you can see first of all we include the
uh the spark cluster construction logic
inside this function and also look at
this Lambda function this is actually
the co-computing logic when the data is
already grouped and shuffled by spark
and this log this Lambda logic is
actually just a pandas logic but in
order to test this function you have to
have a spark cluster up and running and
also
um you are not able to test the core
logic because this cool logic is
embedded in the in the my app function
so a pattern design for the subtract
means might be in this way you can
separate your functions to three
different functions the first function
is your core Computing logic where the
input and output are both pen is
different so this function has nothing
to do with spark you should do full unit
tests on on this function and for the
second part which is spark dependent
and we have modified this function to
taking that spark session where it does
not need to construct that smack session
inside this function
and also you can invoke this subtract
domain inside this function so that you
have minimized the spot dependent logic
in this function and
in the third function
it is all about how you create the smart
cluster or tear downl
so with this cons was this uh design you
will be able to make move a lot of tests
to the upper levels
so you can do unit test integration
tests and acceptance test on different
parts
about is you should try to avoid
framework driven mindset so remember
that we talk about the three layers when
you design with big data applications
actually you should try to maximize the
core Computing logic that is framework
agnostic because this part is the most
testable part and it is independent from
any framework from any uh distributed
framework
and for the second part you should try
to minimize try to minimize the
framework dependent code
and for the framework specific logic of
course you should try to minimize and
more importantly you should try to
centralize the logic so that all the
tests will cover that and so that you so
so that all the acceptance tests can
make sure that the framework specific
logic is working as expected
let's take a look at another example
so assume that we want to process a data
frame
it has four columns a b c and d they're
all strings there are some nouns
and what we want to do is for any given
row if there are more than one normal
value and then we just sort the values
and concatenate them together as a new
string as a new value in the E column
but if there are too many nouns then we
just drop this row
so now let's see with this business
requirements how we implement this logic
in spark.scan Array
so in spark it's very natural to think
about using math partitions right but if
you want to use a member partitions
there is a requirement your function has
to take an iterator of spark rows as the
input
so but as soon as you put this iterator
of rows as your input this function is
no longer independent from spark so in
order to test this function or in order
to test any part of this logic you have
to have a smart cluster so the unit has
to becomes very very difficult
the coupling is too strong
and if you want to implement this in
task then it's probably better task is
pandaslike right so the first thing
comes to your mind maybe that okay maybe
I should use
um pandas apply in order to use Panda
Supply the requirement for this function
is to to taking a panda series
the nice thing is that Panda series
itself has nothing to do with any
distributed computing Frameworks so it
is just the local function that you can
do the unit test but the problem is this
apply function this applies semantic of
pandas does not take care of filtering
so in order to do the filtering you
still have to have the filtering logic
in my app
that means your co-computing logic does
not really
um cover the entire business
requirements
and in order to test everything you
still have to have a smart that's the
cluster you still have to do the
integration test
right so if you want to implement this
logic in Gray then Ray has less options
less log can dusk actually the only
thing you could consider is using data
sets and a map of edges and in
mathematics you can specify for each of
the small batch you can set it the
format to pandas so now you can write a
Penance code
to solve your problem and the nice thing
about this function is now it has
everything it has the apply function it
also has the filtering
and so with this design you have
maximized the unit testable part you
have maximized the part that is agnostic
to any distributed Frameworks
and to be fair
um spark and the task also have the
similar functions to the similar apis to
taking core logic as the map of edges
function but that will require you to
learn more about spark and dusk
um and another thing is because they
have too many options probably the the
first thing
comes to your mind will not be this type
of solution
right so it seems like we have achieved
the best structure in this code but is
this the best solution that we can do so
actually if we take this cool logic out
there can be an alternative solution
so look at this alternative solution we
will see that
what if we're taking the data frame as
iterable of list and output ether above
list
with this assumption actually you can
see that the code is very simple and
very expressive and this code has
nothing to do with pandas
but the ugly thing is that in order to
use this function
you have to convert dependence data
frame to two-dimensional python array
process and then construct the pandas
data frame
so there is a concern that this wrapping
logic can be time consuming compared to
the previous one where we just use the
pandas native functions but is that true
actually if you do the Benchmark you
will see that this solution is 50 times
faster than the previous solution
so let's take a step further what if we
just use this process logic as our core
logic so the cool logic can be expressed
in this way
right this has nothing to do with any
framework it's just python native
and this is the simplest one and as we
know this is also the fastest one even
with the wrapping logic
so now the question is why
it is not the first solution that we can
think about
at the first place
so assume that assume that you are a
beginner of python assume that you don't
know spark task or Ray and you don't
even know pandas this is probably the
first solution
you can think about so what's the
problem
I think the problem is we have so many
tools to use
and so in a lot of times what distracted
by the tools
in a lot of cases our mindset is
how to use XYZ to solve the problem
but if you can change your mindset
what can we do as much as possible as
much as possible
before using XYZ
so if you practice in this way
you probably get more independent from
those tools that works for you
and if you practice in this way probably
the first solution comes to your mind
will be this one the most expressive and
the fastest one
okay now let's talk about good practices
so here is the last example uh in this
presentation
we have NYC taxi example which is pretty
popular and we know that the data set is
publicly available on the website here
is the background background of that
data set in the data ranges from 2009 to
2022.
and the data size for each parquet is
from 50 megabytes to 150 megabytes each
packet file contains one month of data
which parquet file has roughly 20
columns actually we only need two the
pickup date time and the location ID
so there are 242 different locations and
each row represents a right
what we want to do is for each location
we want to build a Time series
forecasting model to predict the hourly
total number of pickups so as you can
see for this data frame you will need
some aggregations to aggregate on the
hour and the location ID and then to get
the total count
and based on that you want to build a
forecasting model I'm not going to dive
deep into the technical details of this
machine learning problem instead we will
just focus on this workflow so on the
first step it is very easy for you to
come up with a solution where to
download one month of data aggregate the
location an hour also with no matter
spark.com array it will be very easy to
distribute this type of task to run this
on full scale on the full data range
okay and on the Second Step you will
just Union all data repartition by
location and sort by hour now you get
for each location you get a Time series
you can train and predict and to get the
predicted value on the given Horizon and
in the end it's just to save the
predicted value to a file
so now the question is given this
workflow how do you test it
here is the first testing strategy which
is also what I commonly see from data
practitioners
because the first step is fairly easy so
they just write everything at one time
and around the full scale on the full
data range
after that what they do is they just do
a spot check ad hoc small check
and see if there is any problem if there
is a problem they will go back change
the code and the wrong at full scale
again until there is no problem and now
the second step is just to implement
everything on the on the rest of the
pipeline and then they just do another
ad hoc spell check
and after these two slot checks
if everything looks fine so they will
just ship it
and think about that
the workflow that you shipped actually
has no written test
and actually there is no protection on
the quality and the correctness
right so this is obviously a sub-optimal
solution
so now let's
think in another way
how can we improve our uh the
testability of of the workflow so first
of all it is a trivial to write the code
to get one month of data and aggregate
by location an hour now why not just
directly added unit test to it
particularly you need all data
repartition and the sort this operation
is also straightforward and you can also
have a unit test knowledge and on the
third step train predicts for one
location you probably can provide some
more data and to train a simple model
and predict and to assert on the
prediction so you can have another unit
tests these three unit tests can cover
almost the most part of your workflow
and actually none of them will have
anything to do with the distributed
backhand you want to use
okay now at this point what you what you
may do is just to get another month of
data
right and pick another location to do
train and predict
and then to save everything too far
so now probably at this point inevitably
you will have to use your the
distributed backhand you want to use
right but at this point you are still
dealing with very small amount of data
so this is the best time to add an
integration test
so for this integration test you can use
either smart task or Ray to run
everything end to end but notice that
you are still just getting two months of
data and training on two locations
so it it will it will not take a lot of
time it will not take a lot of compute
resource you can have very fast
iteration if you find any problems
after this integration now let's see
maybe we can run the first step at full
scale
and now after you run full scale I would
recommend that
you should add a data validation step
as your acceptance tests
data validation can run not only when
you develop your workflow but also when
you run your workflow in production
so it is a very good way to protect your
workflow
and now let's run full scale on train
and predict
and let's add another data validation
step as acceptance test
so then you can see that after this
after this acceptance test we'll have a
very good uh very reliable workflow and
it's well covered by unit tests
introversion tests and acceptance tests
to sum up best practices
you should try to be tester driven
um it is difficult but if you get used
to it you will find
um it can make your pace faster and
faster
always try to unit test the small data
on the core logic unit it can
effectively improve your tester coverage
you should try to do integration tests
before running at full scale that can
save you time and money
and also try to add data validation
steps into the workflows as your
acceptance tests
the last but not least I want to say
that
tests should reflect the requirements of
each logic unit no matter small or big
so they should be the most readable and
most expressive parts of your code
okay so now let's talk about
um Fugue so field is a unified
abstraction of computing Frameworks
as we know on the local side we have
sequolite.d python pandas as our
Computing engine
on the distributed side we have spark
that's in Red so Fugue is a bridge
between the local system and distributed
system it is an abstraction layer it
lets you write one copy of code that can
run seamlessly and consistently on
different backhands including log 1
distributed packets
so the value of Fugue in terms of Big
Data applications is in terms of testing
Big Data applications is that it removes
the framework dependent logic
so recall that we talked about the three
layer design for Big Data applications
right so what field can do is it can
totally remove the framework dependent
parts
instead it will have a very thin layer
of field obstruction that is also
framework agnostic
so with this design you will see that
the need of integration test is almost
uh non-existent
so let's take a look at an example
so here is the function that we talk
about the first example right so now
let's see how we can rewrite my app
using fugue
to make it more testable
we just import the transform from Fugue
and inside the my app we just call the
transform function where you can notice
that the input of my app has been
changed right so the previous one takes
in a spark session and a pandas data
frame right now we're taking any type of
data frame and we also have an engine uh
engine parameter so all these parameters
will be passed into the transform
function
so why do we want to rewrite in this way
now let's see how a unit test this my
app
in order to test this you just need to
pass in a pandas data frame without
setting the engine so in this way field
goal just to translate your logic in on
to into pandas logic so the
transformation will just happen locally
and the outputs will just be appendix
different you can make assertion on that
so this is just a simple unit test
if you want to run this function at
scale on different distributed backends
you just need to specify the engine to
be spark session that's client array and
also for the data frame you can use task
you can use spark data frame that's
different already data set you have the
full flexibility
but for testing you only need to care
about unit testing
so here is the second example the
customer logic as we discussed this the
simplest version of this customer logic
is also the best we can do right but the
question is how can we scale out this
logic so again if you just need to use
this transform function
the data frame can be any type of data
frame spark or task or array and then
you can directly use this cool logic SEO
Transformer to transform your data
the nice thing about Fugue is that
it does not
require you to end use any certain data
type as your input and output it's not
like spark.com array they have their
specific requirements but in Fugue it
adapts to your own function as long as
you have the type annotation let's see
the first example we use Panda 3 frame
as input and output
and in the second example we use
iterable as input and output but as long
as you have the type annotation fig will
handle the data conversion for you
you can just focus on the logic and try
to use the most reasonable and the
intuitive way to express your business
logic
and also by the way for a few projects
we keep the test coverage to be 100 all
the time so
you can trust the system is reliable
okay on the third example for the NYC
texting think about that what you can do
is you can directly convert this
integration test to a unit test because
at this step you do not even need any
distributed backhand to test few things
end to end
in addition
you can have the data validation using
FIB for example like in last year's Pi
data talk I talk about how to use Fugue
and Pandera Fugue and Great Expectations
together to do to do scalable data
validation so here what you can do is
you can add a step where you use Fugue
and Pandera together as the validation
step
so in this way
even with acceptance tests you can run
everything just using your local
execution engine and the way you want to
run this f scale just to change the back
end
and change the input
it will run at full scale
so in addition to this example
let's
talk about the testability of SQL so
assume that in this workflow we have
already get all the data and save them
save the raw data into a distributed
data frame a distributed database let's
assume this database is Hive or you can
assume this is like for example bigquery
tables right so what we can do to
extract the data is just using this very
simple very expressive SQL SQL statement
but the question is how can we test the
SQL what do we often hear is that SQL is
not testable but actually this is not
true especially with Cube so in Cube we
have Fugue SQL which has superset of
um which is a superset of the
traditional SQL
so
um here is an example how we tested this
SQL
we import this F SQL function around the
SQL and but we just specify that this
data source hiked.src table to be a
pandas data frame
and then we just run the whole SQL on
that DB
what does this mean this means when I
feel sicko to identify the data source
of the sequel
and Mark this pay mark this data source
using a given Panda State frame and run
everything using that DB so everything
will just happen locally
and the output will also be a penis will
be a local data frame so you can make a
search around that and it can be
adjusted pure unit test
if we take a step further actually a
fixed SQL can let you express your logic
end to end so the first step is to get
data and the second step is to use the
transform function to do the distributed
train and predict and the next step is
save right and this string predictor
function can be a pure python function
that has nothing to do with any
distributed backend it's fully unit
testable and for the whole pipeline how
can we test it
so actually it is very similar first of
all you just Mark the input data source
as a panda data frame and then you
support this path as a local path and
run everything using that DB
after you do that you will get a file at
local at your local path just extract
the data from the local path and assert
on this data frame
right so again it is still a unit test
so how can we make this run on spark or
some other backhands you just need to
remove this parameter this Hive SRC
table so that this SQL will get the data
from a real data source and also change
this execution engine to be a spark
session and then your whole pipeline now
will run just on the spark backhand and
the reading the real data source
so to sum up
all classes are used for all types of
tests are used for therefore different
purposes we need to use them
strategically
an application design really matters you
should try to separate out framework
independent logic and minimize the
dependent part
and you should try you should not be
driven by your tools tools work for you
but you do not work for your tools
and feel lets you focus on the two
agnostic codes you can write less code
but with more test coverage
thank you
thanks Han for such a wonderful talk on
dusk and yeah we have a little bit of
questions that people have
put up yeah so
do these three unit tests run at each
step by castutis
to this three unit tests run at each
step did you mean the
um
sorry let me just change
see
did you mean the unit three unit tests
here
um so this three unit tests uh they
should they are for different logic
components
but if you want to run the unit tests so
the larger components they should be
written together right so the unit tests
will run together
yeah
okay I hope it answers the question
another one by ludovico is I'm not sure
I followed the reasoning behind the
performance consideration when comparing
the pandas and vanilla python solution
wouldn't the relative performance
strongly depend on the data size
your comments on that the reasoning of
performance uh
I'm not so sure about the performance
what performance you are you talk about
I don't know which part you you refer to
sorry can you uh clarify that
follow the reasoning behind the
performance consideration when comparing
a penis or vanilla python solution
oh I see oh I see what you mean
um so the performance consideration
sometimes it can be true sometimes it
can be false right so in this particular
case we find that using the iterable
using the iterable is even faster than
using the native pandas solution right
so I think the point I want to make here
is that pandas is not always faster than
python and when you know pandas people
tend to have the the assumption that
okay pandas is always better dependence
is always faster so it so if if you
become more too agnostic you could think
more freely and I think what is the most
important is
try to think about what is the real need
for your business logic
right and I think that is the most
important thing performance is the
second important thing and the example I
want to show here is that python native
python is not necessarily slower than
than pandas so you shouldn't always
assume that
um you should use one tool instead of
instead of another